what I have attempted to draw here is a
unit a unit circle and the fact that I'm
calling it a unit circle means it has a
radius of one so this length from the
center and I centered it at the origin
this length from the center to any point
on the circle is of length one so what
would this coordinate be right over
there
right where it intersects along the x
axis well it would be X would be one Y
would be zero well with this coordinate
be up here well we've gone one above the
origin but we haven't moved to the left
or the right so our x value is 0 or Y
value is 1 what about back here well
here our x value is negative 1 we've
moved one to the left and we haven't
moved up or down so our Y value is 0 and
what about down here well our we've gone
what we've gone a unit down or one below
the origin but we haven't moved in the X
Y Direction so our X is 0 and our Y is
negative 1 now with that out of the way
I'm going to draw an angle and then this
the way I'm gonna draw this thing I'm
gonna define a convention for positive
angles I'm gonna say a positive angle
well the terminal sucks like the initial
side of an angle we're always going to
do along the positive x axis so this is
the you can kind of view it as a
starting side of the angle the initial
side of an angle and then to draw an
angle a positive angle the terminal side
we're going to go we're gonna we're
gonna move in a counterclockwise
direction so positive angle means we're
going counter clockwise counter
clockwise this is just the convention
I'm going to use and it's also the
convention that is typically used and so
you can imagine a negative angle would
move in a clockwise clockwise direction
so let me draw a positive angle so a
positive angle might look might look
something like this this is the initial
side and then from that I go in a
counterclockwise direction until I get
until I measure out the angle and then
this is the terminal side so this is a
positive angle theta
and what I want to do is think about
this point of intersection between the
terminal side of this angle and my unit
circle and let's just say it has the
coordinates a comma B the x-value where
it intersects is a the y-value it
intersects is B and I'm also the whole
point of what I'm doing here is I'm
going to see how this unit circle might
be able to help us extend our
traditional definitions of trig
functions and so what I want to do is I
want to make this theta part of a right
triangle so to make it part of a right
triangle let me drop an altitude right
over here and let me make it clear that
this is a 90 degree angle so this this
theta is part of this right triangle so
let's see what we can figure out about
the sides of this right triangle so the
first question I have to ask you is what
is the length of the hypotenuse what is
the length of the hypotenuse of this
right triangle that I have just
constructed well this hypotenuse is just
a radius of a unit circle the unit
circle has a radius of 1 so the
hypotenuse has length 1 now what is the
length of this blue side right over here
this blue side you could view this as
the opposite side to the angle
well this height is the exact same thing
is the exact same thing as the
y-coordinate of this point of
intersection of so this height right
over here is going to be equal to be
this the y-coordinate right over here is
B this height is equal to B now exact
same logic what is the length of this
base going to be the base just of just
of the right triangle well this is going
to be the x-coordinate of this point of
intersection if you were to drop this
down this is the point X is equal to a
or this whole length between the origin
and that is of length is of length a now
that we have set that up what is what is
the cosine and what is the cosine you
same green what is the cosine of my
angle going to be in terms of A's and
B's and any other numbers that might
show up well to think about that we just
need our sohcahtoa definition that's the
only one we have now we are actually in
the process of extending it sohcahtoa
definition of trig functions and the cop
part is what helps us with cosine it
tells us that the cosine of an angle is
equal to the length of the adjacent side
over the hypotenuse so what's this going
to be the length of the adjacent side
for this angle the adjacent side has
length a so it's going to be equal to a
over what's the length of the hypotenuse
well that's just 1 so the cosine of
theta is just equal to a let me write
this down again so the cosine of theta
is just equal to a it's equal to the
x-coordinate of where this terminal side
of the angle intersected the unit circle
now let's think about the sine of theta
sine of theta and I'm going to do it in
let me see I'll do it in orange so
what's the sine of theta going to be
well we just have to look at the so part
of our sohcahtoa definition it tells us
that sine is opposite over hypotenuse
well the opposite side here has length B
and what the hypotenuse has length 1 so
our sine of theta our sine of theta is
equal to B so an interesting thing this
coordinate this point where our terminal
side of our angle intersected the unit
circle that point a B we could also view
this as a is the same thing as cosine of
theta a is the same thing as cosine of
theta and B is the same thing B is the
same thing as sine of theta well that's
interesting that was just we use our
sohcahtoa definition now can we in some
way use this to extend sohcahtoa csoka
Toa has a problem it works out fine if
our angle is greater than 0 degrees if
we're dealing with degrees and if it's
less than 90 degrees we can always we
can always make it part of a right
but sohcahtoa starts to break down as
our angle is either zero or maybe even
becomes negative or as our angle is 90
degrees or more you can't have a right
triangle with two 90-degree angles and
it starts to break down let me make this
clear so sure that's so this is a right
triangle so the angle is pretty large I
could make the angle even larger and
still have a right triangle even larger
but I can I can never get quite to 90
degrees at 90 degrees it's not clear
that I have a right triangle anymore it
all seems to break down and especially
the case what happens when I go beyond
90 degrees so let's go let's see if we
can use what we set up here let's set up
a new definition of our trig functions
which is really an extension extinct an
extension of sohcahtoa and it's
consistent with sohcahtoa instead of
defining cosine as oh if i have a right
triangle and saying okay it's the
adjacent over the hypotenuse sine is the
opposite over the hypotenuse tangent is
opposite over adjacent why don't I just
say for any angle I can draw it in the
unit circle using this convention that I
just set up and let's just say that the
cosine of our angle the cosine of our
angle is equal to the x-coordinate where
we intersect is equal to the
x-coordinate coordinate where the
terminal side of our angle intersects
the unit circle where where angel I'll
write the terminal side terminal side of
angle side of angle intersects
intersects the unit the unit circle and
why don't we define sine of theta sine
of theta to be equal to the y-coordinate
where the terminal side of the angle
intersects the unit circle so
essentially for any angle this point is
going to define cosine of theta and what
sine of theta and so what would be a
reasonable definition for tangent of
theta well tangent of theta
even with sohcahtoa could be defined as
sine of theta over cosine of theta
which in this case is just going to be
the y-coordinate where we intersect the
unit circle over the x-coordinate in the
next few videos I'll show some examples
where we use the unit circle definition
to start evaluating some trig ratios